>> Hello, YouTube.
My name is Bill George.
I'm a professor at Harvard Business School,
wrote a book called "True
North" and I am passionate about leadership
and I think the most
important thing that we can do in 2008 is
to select leaders who are
more committed to the global community than
they are to their personal
self-interest.
We need leaders who know how to collaborate
across country, company,
and NGO lines and bring people together in
a collaborative sense to --
to change the world and start addressing the
really tough problems we
have in the world like health care, poverty,
global peace, education,
and until we to that, I don't think we're
gonna get there until we get
a new generation of leaders and so I'm really
interested in seeing the
new generation of leaders to overthrow the
baby boomers and step up to
take on leadership roles and start making
this world a better place
right now.